hi everybody uh
looks like we got a lot of people here
it's great
um
so i guess yeah welcome to the live
stream on gravity let's see if we can
have some fun today
[Music]
all right
minimize that
hopefully my my audio was good
looks pretty good on my end
all right
uh looks like we got a busy chat which
is great news
so uh this is gonna be you know a pretty
standard live q a i'm gonna be taking
questions from the chat as much as i can
um
hopefully it's not too much of a mad
house
and we'll see if we can uh
you know address some of your concerns
answer some of your questions and um i
think it'll be a good time
so on that note
uh first of all
um
yeah nasa shirt
you actually i don't know you can
actually see that i think i think we're
good
um all right
so let's see here
uh i don't know
how many of you have seen my general
relativity playlist but
um i think
i'll just
assume you basically haven't seen
anything and
uh we'll see where where this takes us
all right so um
first of all
just to get some
some clarity here right we are going to
be sticking to
gravity as it is described in general
relativity that's einstein's version of
gravity that was published in 1915 now i
say einstein but it was also weinstein
and hilbert and grossman and there was a
whole bunch of other people that worked
on it
um it wasn't just one person uh but the
big names are definitely einstein and
hilbert
they published a lot of the same papers
around the same time and you know
1915-ish
throughout the year
so um it was a collaborative type
project
um and of course a lot of the things
that you
are familiar with
black holes and stuff like that that
came out of it were not part of the
original papers that einstein and
hilbert published they were
things that came out afterward as other
scientists you know other physicists got
their hands on that stuff
um
so
there may be times today where things
get a little mathy but what i'm going to
do is i'm going to be pulling out
um a few pages from
the general relativity chapter in my
book and
so you'll have some visual aids as we go
i can screen share during the stream
uh but
i guess first let's start with some
questions um we have one uh that came in
before the stream started
by 10 boxing and his question was uh
about
science clicks
visuals uh science click english i think
is the
channel that most people are familiar
with um and
he put out a video
where he had
some uh
they're called geodesics they're the
paths that you take in space time
um
and they
were appointed you know they sort of
curved toward the earth and the object
the apple i think was in the visual
followed it down to the ground and i've
done that in a few of my general
relativity videos some of the older ones
especially
um geodesics are a big deal they are the
shortest i should say the extremal path
between two points they're the things
that uh outside of you know other forces
like electromagnetism or something
those are the paths that
things are going to take
and sometimes those are straight and
sometimes those are curved and that's
sort of what general relativity is all
about
um and ten boxing's question was if you
had
a planet made of water
uh would that would that curve go all
the way to the center and absolutely 100
it would yes
now
whether or not an entire planet made of
water is possible is a whole other story
um
but
given that situation given the very
unlikely situation yes the path would
would go all the way down toward the
center and eventually that would stop
and that object would sort of become
part of
the overall path the overall geodesic of
the earth or that planet orbiting its
star
um
but while we're talking about geodesics
right this this stuff is all sort of
mathematical um and so what i'm gonna do
is i'm actually gonna
i'm gonna screen share real quick i
think i could just do that hopefully
that works woo infinity
uh all right and so
what i have here
is um
the general relativity chapter in my
book and
geodesics are on let's see here
uh 305.
all right so
what we have here zoom in a little bit
uh don't freak out about the math i'm
going to be explaining everything as i
go
but basically this is
the geodesic equation hopefully you can
see that
um
oops
i'll pull up the chat here so i can see
it
and respond to people but uh this is the
geodesic equation and essentially
this is
half of the story right this is one of
the two
major equations in general relativity
basically um there's this there's a
statement that uh i think um john
archibald wheeler said one time that was
it said that uh
matter tells space-time how to curve and
space-time tells matter how to move
um and that is true and those two
those two halves of that statement
are basically the
the concepts the overall concepts behind
the two major equations in general
relativity that is einstein's field
equation which we'll get to at some
point today i'm sure
and the geodesic equation which is
uh i think this way
this this equation up here
um
and so essentially what this is this is
sort of a version of
uh
this is sort of a generalization of
newton's laws right so before einstein
we had newton's laws of motion and
newton's law of gravity and that's sort
of
how most things worked and and it works
pretty well like 99 of the time
but
this
equation here
is sort of a generalization of that
right um in this case
uh typically when you think of newton's
laws you think of f equals m a force is
mass times acceleration it's sort of the
one of those like the major equations in
an intro physics class
um where you exert a force on a mass and
that causes an acceleration and that
that sort of
behavior
is
is something that that happens in
in einstein's
uh model as well
we're still trying to explain motion via
things like forces um
and so in this particular case i don't
know if you can see my mouse pointer
um
yeah it's there okay so
the
mouse
right here this this term right here
looks real fancy i don't know if you're
familiar with calculus but that's
basically the acceleration that first
term
and this zero over here would be
uh
f divided by m right so this would
basically be if you you didn't have this
big term here we're gonna ignore that
for a second you would have a
equals f over m now in this case the way
this is typically written
uh the f is zero there's no forces
acting on the object so there's no
electromagnetism no strong or weak
nuclear forces none of that stuff
um
gravity isn't a force and so it doesn't
get included in in the force side so we
get zero
uh the force is zero and in newton's
laws you would expect the acceleration
to be zero but
that's not always the case
and so as you can see here according to
the geodesic equation
uh we have the acceleration term but we
also have this term here
these big fractions they're not really
fractions but these big fractions are
the motion of an object
and then this um this is a greek a
capital gamma but
this is something called a christopher
symbol and it has to do with
um
the curvature and you know the your
space time as well as like the
coordinates you're choosing to represent
it both
both things are included in there
and
uh and so this big term here this term
represents the curvature of the space
time and so uh what ends up happening is
you can end up with an acceleration just
because of curvature you don't actually
need a force and so
uh
what general relativity is saying
here is that
sometimes a force can cause an
acceleration that is true that is that
that carries over from newton's laws but
also
that curvature
can cause acceleration
and so
general relativity is sort of uh the
realization that not all accelerations
are caused by forces
which is kind of wild to think about but
that's essentially what the geodesic
equation says it says that
um
you know sometimes forces can cause
accelerations but ultimately if you
don't have any forces acceleration can
still happen
um if the space time is curved and that
usually happens around something right
which brings us to
einstein's equation
which
i have a little posted here with all my
page numbers
um einstein's equation 272.
and so scroll down a little bit
all right and so this bad boy
is einstein's equation and this is sort
of the big the one that everybody knows
about right and this is the first half
of the statement this tells us how
matter or i should really say energy
curve space time because as it turns out
light
can also curve space time it doesn't
have to be matter it doesn't have to
have
rest mass
um
so
uh in this case on the right side this
big fraction is just a constant we can
basically ignore that this t here
represents all of the
you know the the what the the matter and
light looks like
and
then this whole right side over here is
these are curvature tensors which you
know if someone is interested and wants
to ask we can talk about those too but
uh basically this tells us that
matter and light
curve space time and so then we go to
the geodesic equation and now that we
know how it's curved we can determine
how something else some other matter or
some other light is going to behave
inside of that space time right and so
this is what we call a this is i mean
it's
it looks
fancy and the math kind of tensor tensor
math is
very unique and so it can look kind of
fancy but this is essentially just
a
any just like any other classical field
theory we've you know if you're familiar
with electrodynamics you've got
maxwell's equations which tell you how
you know
charges can create electric charges can
create electronic magnetic fields and
then we've got the lorentz force which
tells us how those electromagnetic
fields can
affect other things right so that's sort
of how classical field theories work
and
um and in this case by classical we mean
non-quantum
but uh
essentially we have objects that affect
fields that then affect other objects
that's how a field theory works
and so these are the two
basic equations behind
behind uh general relativity this is how
it functions and if you know how to do
tensor math you can
you can actually get very specific
geometries you can figure out what the
space time looks like around you know a
at least a small set of objects
and so that's sort of how it works
uh all right another question from the
chat says
uh hey nick do you think we'll figure
out dark matter and or dark energy in
the next 20 to 40 years
um
man that's that's a tough question i
mean
i don't necessarily like to
i
i don't know
if
when you make predictions like that
about the future you end up
with
you can end up in a position where
you're you're wrong and a lot of people
that make predictions about the future
are wrong i mean we've been predicting
you know nuclear fusion power for a long
time we're like oh no 10 year 20 years
it'll have 20 years from now and then 20
years passes and it doesn't happen and i
don't know 20 more years
um
and so i would like to think that we'll
figure out dark matter and dark energy
in the next 20 to 40 years but
it's tough stuff to study
um dark matter is easier because at
least we know that it's matter we we we
have some kind of familiarity with it
uh we don't necessarily know what kind
of matter it is i'm gonna get off the
screen share here
um all right
we don't necessarily know what kind of
matter it is but we do know
that it is matter it has the behavior of
matter that is very consistent with what
we see it do
and so um
that's just a uh
for
for uh
you know pun
here it's just a matter of
um figuring out what type of matter it
is
and that's the tricky part but i think
that
is probably doable in
i mean
definitely 40 years i would think
um
20 might be a bit ambitious but uh
i feel like we could figure out dark
matter in 40 years dark energy
is trickier dark energy is a completely
different thing not only
is it not matter it can't be matter
um we
we only know it's it's
it's energy it's an energy term in
einstein's equation in fact why don't i
screen share this
um
that happens to be
uh somewhere around here
i'm not sure i have it
there it is
um
okay so this
is einstein's equation with
the cosmological constant in it and this
is sort of the foundation of
of uh
dark energy right this term right here
this dark energy term get that back
this is the cosmological constant this
big um
lambda right there
and we say it's a constant every every
term in this equation is not an energy
it's an energy density
and so what that means it's you know if
we measure energy in say joules or
something
um this each term in this equation is a
joules per cubic meter it's an energy
density
um
and so
what you end up with
is
you end up with this term at the end
that is
a
a constant energy density which means
that as space expands
you end up having to have more and more
energy in the space because you have to
keep the density the same if the density
didn't
you know if
you didn't create more and more of this
stuff this dark energy
then the density of it would go down
just like the density of matter and the
density of light go down as space
expands
but
according to general relativity that
can't happen with dark energy and so
it's kind of this weird
it has a very weird behavior it's very
alien it isn't anything that we're
familiar with and so
i don't know if we'll figure that one
out in 40 years
that's gonna be a lot
harder
um i'd be very excited if we do it's a
big deal for me i love cosmology but
uh
i don't know if 40 years is 40 years is
ambitious
for something we barely understand
let's see
um
someone said is it true that calculus is
what allowed einstein to come up with
the theory of relativity well
no cause
his i mean back in the day when he was
doing special relativity this is before
gravity and everything
he
didn't even use calculus it was all
algebra and thought experiments
um he didn't really need calculus until
general relativity and then plain old
calculus just wasn't enough and he was
kind of stuck and he didn't know what he
was doing and then he talked to a couple
of his math professor friends um like
marcel grossman i think marcel is his
name
um
and
they sat down with him and discussed it
at you know you know talked it out and
then they're like okay well you're gonna
need
you're gonna need differential geometry
and you're gonna need uh tensor analysis
and those are the maths you need to
learn and so he went off and he learned
those things he hadn't he didn't need to
learn that stuff when he was getting his
degrees um
and so he had to learn that stuff
before he could finish general
relativity um
and i'm sure this is what put david
hilbert at an advantage because david
hilbert was a mathematician so here was
already familiar with a lot of these
things
um but it wasn't calculus it was
tensors and differential geometry that
made it possible but it wasn't like he
had to wait for that stuff though that
that mathematics had been around
for a long time like at least a century
before he was even born so
um he just had to find it someone had to
tell him to use it
um
let's see
what else we have here we have some good
questions in the chat
uh
richie is coming guys get ready for
messy equations uh yeah uh that's that's
definitely i mean if that someone asks
i'll i'll pull that out uh let's see
uh
did you
oh there's a lot of
a lot of questions all right so let's
see here
uh your latest video your latest gravity
video um
gravity was caused by the flow of
gradient in time uh yeah we're gonna
talk about that
uh would dark energy imply the time
flows opposite there with that concept
uh no
because when you get into dark energy
you're sort of stepping
beyond what
that video was intended to cover
uh all right so
a year two years ago maybe two years ago
i put out a video
um where i said ordinary everyday
gravity the gravity that we experience
here on earth for example is
is caused by um what i call the flow
gradient in time and and the the fact of
the matter is
that
basically everything that ever happens
ever in the universe is caused by some
kind of gradient it's always a gradient
um
and so when it comes to newton's version
of gravity it was like an energy
gradient you had potential gravitational
potential energy but
um
general relativity kind of changed all
that and it turned out to be gradients
in space time
but uh when you're talking about
um something we call the weak field
approximation which um makes it sound
like
uh the term weak
is
it might seem a bit subjective but
basically what that means is um
any
any field
that could be
easily explained by newton's version of
gravity um
and so uh that for earth fits that
example earth's gravity fits that
example
and so
in that case right if you want to
explain a weak field like the one around
the earth uh earth is
pretty small and not all that compact
and so
it's but it's it's i should say it's
pretty low mass uh but not all that
compact and so um
astronomically speaking the the
gravitational field around the earth is
pretty small
pretty weak
um but
in that case right even though newton's
law of gravity works you want to be able
to explain it
using
[Music]
um using the new model right even if the
old model works you want to make sure
the new model is at least consistent um
and when you do that if you do that that
sort of weak gravity um it turns out
that the
time term the temporal term
dominates
by a landslide dominates the behavior of
what's happening and so um i was able to
make a video talking about that and
about how the gravity that you
experience that you know makes things
fall to the ground when you drop them or
you know
you fall to the ground when you skydive
out of a plane or whatever
um that it has to do with differences in
the flow of time at various heights
above the earth right
um and that flow gradient
is ultimately still caused by the mass
of the earth
uh mass is just confined energy and
energy is what causes that sort of thing
and so
um
objects large objects like planets and
stars and stuff just slow down time
around them
and gravity is
kind of an
accidental byproduct of that right i see
someone asked if gravity was real
yes
um
i mean i suppose it depends on what you
mean by real but it's a real effect it's
a real thing that happens
um it just isn't a force in the
traditional sense
but
it
the
what general relativity says is that it
says that that masses slow down time
and that slow down in time
then causes an effect that we observe as
gravity
um
but the the reason i bring this up is
because
when you talk about things like black
holes or neutron stars or the entire
field that spans the cosmos
which is where dark energy comes up
you don't
have that weak field approximation
anymore you have
a strong field and when you have a
strong field
time flow
is no longer enough to explain what's
happening you need to include space
because now the space curvature is is a
significant has a significant impact on
what's happening
which uh is not true for the gravity
that we personally experience on a daily
basis but it is true
in general
uh so
i don't think that you can use that
video and then and then expand on it to
talk about dark energy you've stepped
beyond the scope of that that analogy
um
uh someone says can we make matter from
energy uh
no that's actually a common
misconception um
matter
i i think the problem is the language
which is honestly what
what
a lot of the issue is like i know that
there are some people that don't like
some of my general relativity videos and
usually after a conversation it comes
down to language
you know the definitions of words and
how i'm defining them versus how they're
defining them and
um that is almost always the result of
like well i'm a science communicator and
so i'm trying to use language that makes
sense to
you know non-scientists and
they're getting on my case for using a
different definition of a word that's
not very scientific or whatever and it
it's going to happen forever i'm i'm
used to it at this point but
uh
the the the language i'm talking about
here is
that matter is a real thing right we
know it's there it exists um and we know
light is a thing right matter and light
are things that exist
energy
is just a number
and the same thing with mass mass is
just a number mass is just confined
energy
and so
energy is just
math it's not
real it's not a real thing that exists
um
unfortunately when people talk about
light
they often refer to it as energy
and it causes all sorts of
misconceptions so when they say oh well
like when you set off this nuclear
explosion
or whatever and energy is released no no
energy is not released
light is released
and that light has energy we can assign
a number to it that we call energy but
it's it light is released real stuff is
released light and particles of matter
and all sorts of stuff right is released
uh during nuclear reactions
um but you're not creating matter from
energy you're creating matter from light
that is a thing that can happen you can
create light from matter and you can
create matter from light they uh
they're kind of interchangeable
um
you can transform one into the other
it's just a matter of like an energy
transformation but
um i i i i would be very careful not to
say
matter is created from energy because
that's not how it works you can't create
a real thing from math that's
it doesn't make sense
um
all right
so let's see here
[Music]
a lot of questions
uh
lots of comments on the nasa shirt
it's very comfortable by the way
oh see
um people asking about good books on
relativity well i just posted a video at
the beginning of the month about that
you should check it out
um
oh just reset okay
matter is a form of energy not
no
matter has energy light has energy
again you got to be very careful with
the language
um
[Music]
we can see the back of our head in the
ergosphere of a black hole uh all right
so yeah let's talk about black holes for
a little bit
black holes are always a crowd pleaser
right
um black holes
all right
black holes are
i have opinions about black holes if you
haven't figured that out from some of my
videos
but um black holes are sort of the
absolute extreme of this effect right
um
and so
it's kind of it kind of ends up being
weird to think about when you actually
get into the math of general relativity
because
black holes are something that we call a
vacuum solution and what that means is
that uh the space-time is completely
void of matter
uh and so when we talk about the
schwarzschild
man i i'm never i'm not even gonna try
and say it i always mess it up
um
but there's the
the original black hole solution to
einstein's equation and it was the first
one it was the first exact solution so
it's a big deal
um but that has to do with like the
perfectly spherical black holes the
basic ones um doesn't include rotation
they're a lot more complicated
but
um
when we look at that extreme there's
sort of the extreme version all the
matter that was there has
um as far as general relativity is
concerned has collapsed into a
singularity uh whether that's actually
true is
a whole different story because um the
word singularity is actually a math term
that just means that uh
we broke the model
um and so
if you break the model it's kind of hard
to argue that it's saying anything about
reality
uh
at least in that particular instance
and so you have to be careful but
black holes are definitely a real thing
we have observed many of them we know
that the centers of galaxies have
supermassive ones
um and we know that you know
typical galaxies are full of regular
sized ones
uh they're all over the place
but
around a black hole right you've got the
event horizon which is the limit of what
we can see
and the that event horizon is
is uh
sort of the definition of a black hole
when we say a black hole we're talking
about the event horizon because we don't
actually know what's happening inside
um and so when we say the black hole is
has a diameter of whatever we're talking
about the event horizon
um
but
even more interesting is if you take one
of those black holes and you make it
spin
weirder stuff happens right at that
point what it can do is you can actually
drag space time around with it and
create this sort of like
um
whirlpool of space-time which is
wild right where it's actually like just
it's physically impossible to sit still
right in order to sit still you would
have to travel faster than light and we
can't travel faster than light so you
can't sit still
um and so
there's this region around the black
hole outside the event horizon
but close called an ergosphere and i did
a video a few years back
on the ergosphere but basically inside
there you you can't sit still and you're
sort of
dragged around as the black hole rotates
um
but right around there right around the
ergosphere there's also something called
the photon sphere
which is where the curvature is so
intense that a photon can orbit the
black hole
right the curvature is so
so strong that the that a path
that light takes
which is the straightest possible path
anything could take
the curvature is so extreme that the the
light actually orbits the black hole
um and in that particular location right
uh
how we see things we see things based on
light and so if you have if you were if
you had your head
at the photon sphere and around a black
hole
and you you faced like
along
the orbit
um
light from the back of your head would
if there was a light if you know the
light to reflect or light reflect off
the back of your head
go all the way around the black hole and
come into your eyes and so you'd be able
to like
see
the back of your head in the distance
um
i'd love to do a video on black hole
optics
but i don't have the
the uh
simulation
skills for it
um i would need to hire someone to sort
of make the
the geometry environment for me um and i
don't know anyone that can do that so
might be a while but but yes
there is a spot where you can look and
you can actually see the back of your
own head because the way the light moves
around it
uh it's wild
um
lily lily says i get the mass effects
curvature and that mass is a property of
energy so therefore energy affects
curvature but why does pressure cause
curvature all right so
new screen share
i've got uh
let's see where is it 280.
all right
so what i've got here
is something we call the stress energy
tensor
which
uh looks complicated it's just a big
matrix of numbers
but um i'm gonna go through and i will
explain it what what all these terms
mean so
this e this little curly e here is just
the energy density it's just
the amount of energy whatever energy is
whatever
energy is confined within the space time
and then the rest of these diagonals is
p1 p2 and p3 are pressure
um which is what uh lily's interested in
but we've also got um these
terms on the top and the side here
which are essentially momentum so it's
about the motion of the matter
or light
and then these little sigmas here are uh
shear forces right so how things are how
parts of the object are shearing against
each other
and so in this particular case right all
of these things
contribute to the curvature of
space-time
all of them
um
and as far as pressure goes if you
actually
look at the units for pressure the units
for pressure are uh newtons per let me
get off the screen share
the units for pressure are in newtons
per square meter if you do this in
standard metric units
but if you multiply the top and the
bottom by a meter what you end up with
is joules per cubic meter and so
uh
you can just think about this in terms
of thermodynamics right when you think
about pressure
in a gas
what that pressure is telling you right
what we think about that pressure is
that oh well that's the that's like the
force
that it's going to exert on its
container per square meter which is true
but it's also
an energy density it's telling you how
much thermodynamic energy is in the
system
right and so where that the curly e is
just the overall like
rest energy
of the stuff
you've also got the motional kinetic
energy of the stuff
um
and also it's
random particle motions within the
system
and
um the the sheer forces to handle like
the other interactions and stuff so like
how
it's not just about how much stuff is
there it's about how all the stuff all
the particles that make up that object
are interacting with each other all of
that is also energy and so all of that
also curves space time
and you have to account for that stuff
um
usually when we're trying to solve these
things we make approximations
and we we ignore some of the terms we
plug in zeros for simplicity but uh you
can't always do that sometimes
objects rotate and
parts of it shear against each other
like stars right something like the sun
um
is going to have a slightly
more complicated curvature around it
than you might expect because of
how the plasma is interacting with
itself so
that interaction matters too
let's see
can you turn slow mode on so q a can be
productive because it's too fast uh it
actually is on
i set
the
uh
comment speed to 30 seconds so people
can't like comment over and over and
over again because the last time i did a
public stream it was
it was crazy we had almost um it was
with physics girl and we had almost a
thousand people there and people were
just spamming the chat and so
i
i decided to turn on the slow mode today
um and it's actually been
fairly productive so
um i am i am seeing people's comments
uh see
uh
um someone said corey graham wants to
know i said that that youtuber claimed
that the earth surface is literally
expanding outward
all right
i knew i was gonna get questions about
this okay so
let's just address this
uh since i know people are in the chat
wondering um
there are always
going to be people
that are going to tell me that i'm wrong
about something and
honestly
sometimes i need to be told i'm wrong
because i'm i'm human i'm wrong
sometimes it happens um i have taken
down videos because i have been told i
was wrong and i was actually wrong it
happens
um
but then other times people tell me that
i'm wrong and i'm not actually wrong
they're just being extra pedantic about
something or
um
they're
what it usually comes down to is this
let me let me give you an analogy so
when i make videos
like this video i did with the flow
gradient in time
was
i think it was a seven minute eight
minute video something like that
i'm not going to be able to cover the
whole picture
in seven or eight minutes um and so what
i have to do is i have to choose
what part of it i'm showing you right so
um
just for an analogy say the the whole
picture is a picture of a person
and what i decided to do was i decided
to show you something i felt was
foundational to the idea right something
to get you actually
started and get your mind in the right
place and so i showed you
a foot
right i showed you the picture of their
shoe
um
and i think that's okay as long as you
know you're clear that that's all you're
doing that you're i'm only showing a
picture of a shoe i'm not showing a
whole person
but then uh people will
you know
they'll
they'll get on my case about it
that i didn't show the whole picture and
that's unreasonable and then i'll i'll
see videos there's there's
there there are whole channels devoted
to trying to debunk me but
um
what ends up happening is uh sometimes
they're just
the person has no idea what they're
talking about and other times they know
what they're talking about
but what they've done is they've shown
you a picture of the hand instead
you know i showed you the shoe and
they're showing you the hand and they're
like well this is what this is what
general relativity is and so that person
over there that showed you a shoe that
that's not human my hand is human
and that's
that's not good that's not a good way to
do this and and i i feel like
i feel like we need as many people as
possible talking about this stuff so
that we can reach as many people as
possible
and so when i do a video like i did the
the
energy flow in an electric circuit video
and then a few years later
derrick muller does one veritasium puts
out a video and everyone's like oh he
copied you he didn't copy me he just
covered the same topic and that's
totally fine that's allowed
um and it's important that that you know
as many people have the discussion as
possible so it'll work out kinks and
it'll it'll it'll be able to reach i
can't possibly reach everyone by myself
it's just not i don't have the style
that reaches everybody
and so i i like that other people cover
the same topics um but if you're gonna
sit there and show a different part of a
topic and then tell me that i'm wrong
because my part
isn't
isn't real like it just doesn't make
sense to me
um
and so
there was a video someone posted
recently where they explained that
uh one way to look at general relativity
is to say that
the earth's surface is accelerating
upward toward the object which
it's technically true
i've never liked it it's never really
resonated with me um
but i mean if you look at the math you
can technically say that
as long as you're defining acceleration
very carefully
but
um
just because you can say the ground is
accelerating up toward the object that
doesn't mean you can say that the entire
earth's surface is accelerating outward
because
something that's very important for
general relativity and this is for the
topic of the live stream is
um is that it's a local model and what
that means is that the math is defined
at a point it is not defined
generally right you can't look at an
equation and be like oh well this is
what the geometry looks like everywhere
no it's it's what the geometry looks
like at whatever point you plug in
right and so if you've got uh the
schwarzschild
metric which is something that describes
the geometry around spherical objects
like black holes or planets or whatever
and
what you can do is you can plug in a
distance from the center you plug in
like you know an altitude plus the
radius of the earth and what you'll get
is the curvature at that distance from
the earth that specific spot
um
and so you can look at the
the point on the earth the earth's
surface underneath the falling apple and
you can be like oh well it's just as
equivalent to say that the earth the
point on that earth surface is
accelerating up toward the apple
but
um you can't say the whole earth's
surface is accelerating outward because
the whole earth's surface is not local
it's a bunch of points
that are all accelerating up toward
objects but that doesn't mean that the
whole surface is accelerating outward
you'd be very very careful about that
um
now there is a way to look at it
where
if if you want to try and imagine that
like space is falling into an object you
might be able to say that oh well at
that point
the surface is accelerating outward but
because space is falling inward at the
same rate
uh the surface doesn't actually go
anywhere even though it's accelerating
and so it's accelerating to stay still
which is even weirder right and i i just
don't feel like
while that's true i don't feel like
people just getting their first
introduction to general relativity are
ready to be exposed to ideas like that
they're just you're not prepared
right you're gonna you're gonna hear a
statement like that and be like oh well
that's ridiculous i'm like this is this
and then you reject the whole thing
which uh you have to be ready right this
is this is weird counter-intuitive stuff
you need to be ready
to hear things
and so there's there's you know a
specific like educational
order
to how
you know and there's a there are stages
in your learning process where you're
ready to hear things you're not ready to
hear things um and when that is can
depend on the person learning but
um
you have to be really careful
about visuals like that and so um when
i'm trying to describe gravity i prefer
to stay in the reference frame of the
earth
when i'm talking about objects falling
toward the earth under gravity
um can you switch to the frame of the
apple and do things from the perspective
of the apple sure but
that is not
the perspective that anyone doing the
experiment is going to have and so it's
going to be a less familiar situation
and if it's less familiar to your
instincts then you're going to make
mistakes
and you know that's the it's just a fact
of humanity right if something is is
beyond too far beyond your experience
mistakes will be made
um and you don't always necessarily know
that you're making mistakes
and so you have to be you have to be
very careful uh and so while
that
explanation isn't wrong
um it doesn't really it doesn't really
sit well with me for an introduction
uh all right
let's see
uh
thanks for all the super chats by the
way jump to this
uh i sometimes use your videos as a
starting point before diving deep
uh into a topic
um
yeah that's why i try to that's how i
try to write the videos and so um i'm
glad that this is how they're coming
across
uh it says who is the little monster
dude on the couch in the back uh this
guy right here
uh that is uh my pet monster
and i don't mean that like he's a
monster and he's my pet like that was
the name there was this okay so
uh
i'm
old as far as the internet is concerned
uh and so back back in the 80s
there was this tv show called my pet
monster
um
and it was like a cartoon monster
superimposed on like
live-action people i think there was a
movie or something maybe too um anyway
when i was a really little kid i was
super into this and so
um when i was like three or four years
old i got him as a christmas present
and i still have him um he used to have
orange
uh hand chain handcuffs which
um the family dog ate at one point and
chewed up and then buried in the
backyard
uh didn't find it again until i was 15
and then we were like you know redoing
the back porch
uh i was redoing the back porch with my
dad and then
all of a sudden oh look it's the
handcuffs uh but
but yeah he's
he's in kind of rough shape but
one of my most prized possessions
uh in this stream you said both energy
isn't a thing it's just math and that
mass is just confined energy both true
statements by the way it says you owe us
a video on the laws of thermodynamics oh
yeah you know
what i really want to do is i want to do
um
i want to do some videos on statistical
mechanics or what we say is uh stat mech
in the the physics community
but um i think that would be fun
um and you know it would explain a lot i
mean there's a lot of background like
that like thermodynamics that
is super helpful
for
you know later physics like quantum
mechanics or general relativity so you
know having a good foundation with that
stuff is important
um
but yeah so i see uh eigen chris is in
the chat i mentioned
uh his channel
and the
the you know the self-study guide that i
put out at the beginning of the month um
definitely check out his his stuff he
goes real deep
so be prepared for some math but um it's
very thorough
uh all right
um does the gravitational constant
change uh
no
as far as we can tell it is in fact
constant now
this is
not a dumb question right um
in fact in my opinion there's no such
thing as a dumb question there's only
questions asked in bad faith
when you're asking a question you don't
actually want to know the answer that's
that's not a cool question but if you're
actually interested and you're curious
that's good and in this this case
um the fact is there are things that
science refers to as constants that
aren't necessarily constants and we're
trying to change the names but
tradition is is hard uh so in the case
of
in the case of uh cosmology since that's
part of that since that's related to
today's topic
um we have this thing called the hubble
constant or at least it used to be
called the hubble constant
which
sort of represents the current expansion
rate of space
and
it's a major part of cosmology and how
general relativity applies to it but
um
it's not really constant the expansion
rate changes over time
uh and we can map it out we know exactly
how it's changed for the last you know
10 billion years or so
um things get a little hazy when we get
to the early universe when we get to
like pre
uh it's called recombination when the
cosmic microwave background was released
like that's as far back as we can see
and so when it gets past that
uh that's when we start to
get a little hazy on what we know about
the universe but um after that we we got
solid data
on on how space has expanded throughout
history
um and it turns out that expansion rate
changes uh
the original models the early models we
assumed it was constant but it turns out
not not to be the case
um and so we're trying to call it the
hubble parameter now instead of the
hubble constant but
you know if you've got old p old
physicists that have been doing this
stuff for
you know 40 50 years
uh they're not going to change they're
just going to keep calling it the hubble
constant and you've got to deal with it
these things take time um but in the
case of the gravitational constant which
is that big g i had an einstein's
equation uh that appears to be the same
everywhere no matter what
um
if it turned out to be changing that
would definitely be interesting but uh
it appears to be constant
lots of people remembering my pet
monster makes me feel less old thank you
let's see
um
we can only travel one direction in
space to change that we need a force
uh
just like traveling through time
um
for space we have something to grab onto
but i mean it's not the same thing
though it's not gravity isn't force it's
curvature
um
but both forces and curvature like i
said at the beginning of the stream can
cause accelerations can cause changes in
direction at least a apparent changes in
direction
uh geometrically it's not a change in
direction which is where the confusion
comes from you can't actually trust your
eyes
in general relativity
um
all right let's see what we got
uh
what do you expect the james webb space
telescope to tell us about gravity and
space time and what should it tell us
about the distance ladder
okay so
we
have the opportunity here this is a big
deal i think um with hubble
the furthest back we were able to look
is 8 billion years or so
which you know seems like a lot but the
universe is almost 14 billion years old
and so
uh for those who don't know the farther
out we look the farther back in time
we're looking we're looking at images of
the past
um
and so
uh
when we look out eight billion light
years we're looking eight billion years
into the past it's really about time
it's not about distance
and so
hubble could really it was it was hubble
was
visible light it saw invisible light and
so we
we could only go back so far
uh after that redshift cosmological
redshift is so extreme that
um visible light has shifted into
infrared and hubble isn't able to see
that but the james face telescope is all
about infrared light and so it has
allowed us to see so much further back
like 13 billion years into the past
which is huge and obviously the data is
still coming in and it's all very new
it's only a few months old
but
um
it's gonna be it's either gonna confirm
what we already know
uh
and any problems we have we still have
or
it's going to
to give us the the data we need to make
adjustments
to fill in the holes that we have and
and that second option is so much more
exciting
right and that's the thing about science
right it's so
exciting to be proven wrong
because the goal the goal is to learn
something right and if you just keep
having confirmations that's that's good
you know but it's not it's not exciting
the the idea of being wrong is so
exciting to scientists
or at least science in general a
scientific community
some scientists might not take it very
well but
uh i think
i think the james webb telescope is
a huge achievement it's a big deal and
it's gonna
it's gonna give us so much data we're
gonna be chewing on it for decades
uh it's a big deal
um they say the universe is flat
but it's not all aligned on a table is
it uh okay so
again this is a language thing
flat doesn't actually mean flat like a
table top or a piece of paper um
not in the sense that you're thinking
the universe has a volume it goes out
the same distance in all directions
um
the observable universe is spherical it
is not a plane
um but
uh in fact we'll we'll pull this up as
well screen share
uh we're looking at
um 328
okay
zoom out a little bit all right so what
we've got here
is
a
[Music]
this is
a description of the curvature of
uh space and time overall like the
cosmological size right
um and
what really matters here is this k value
this is the curvature value
um
and
try not to get overwhelmed by the whole
equation so the k is what matters
and when it comes to that k
we've got a few options
we've got a closed universe a flat
universe and an open universe these are
the
the the words we use to describe these
things but but what flat means flat just
means no curvature right so if you look
at a flat table top it's not curved
right that's the idea behind it and so
when we look at
space and we say that space is not
curved and that is what we see on the
grand scale it turns out that k equals 0
for our universe as far as we can tell
that means that there's no
overall curvature on the cosmic scale
uh and so um
we should really say when we say
closed flat and open you should really
say positive curvature
zero curvature and negative curvature
but that
doesn't feel as approachable and so
um at some point someone decided on
these basic words these standard words
that everybody uses clothes to open a
flat to describe what's going on um and
it's led people down
misconception tracks like this
but the universe goes out in all
directions it is not a flat plane
it is flat and that it is not curved
uh and so if you were to travel long
distances in straight lines those lines
that line that you took that you you
flew on would stay straight
that's the idea
your path through the cosmos would not
curve
but that doesn't mean we're in a flat
plane
um so very very important distinction
let's see
uh
lots of things about negative mass in
here that
that's all speculative and i try to stay
away
from speculative stuff like i tried to
write
uh a video on tachyons that's
hypothetical particles that travel
backward in time i tried to write a
video on it a couple years ago and i
just got angry and quit because they're
so hypothetical like why am i even
discussing this and so i try to
i try not to cover things that are too
speculative or too new
and so there are things that uh you know
you might see on a channel like pbs
spacetime great channel by the way
um
that you wouldn't necessarily see on my
channel because it's just a personal
preference
um and so i'll probably never do a video
that involves negative mass just just
accept it
uh let's see
uh do images like the james webb update
our idea of the amount of mass in the
universe uh they haven't yet
we seem to be expecting
uh we seem to be seeing
exactly what we'd expect
you know galaxies
um the same the right number of galaxies
in the universe
uh and having the correct spacing that
they should have
but
um
it's not
we have been finding galaxies earlier
than we expected and so the timeline
might need to be adjusted which is a big
deal but as far as the amount of mass no
that's basically
exactly as expected
um let's see what happens if the james
webb space telescope takes photos of
clusters that are more than 14 billion
light years away more than the age of
the universe how will the images turn
out uh they won't
we can't see that far back
um we can only see
13.8 billion light years away
uh because
that's how long ago
the first light was emitted
before that light was trapped between
charged particles and there was
essentially no free light to create
images of anything
and so there are no
images before that moment they don't
exist
it's just
it's just a fact of cosmology
um
see
got a lot of questions related to stuff
not just not relativity so i'm skipping
some questions here i apologize to
anyone who's trying to get questions in
uh outside of the the main topic
um let's see
um
lots of questions uh
did the big bang happen
uh
yeah but i mean it wasn't an explosion
and this is a a common misconception
that people have right when we actually
when you actually sit down with the math
and you finally like understand what's
happening um
you
you realize that
things are named very poorly
particularly in physics but i think it's
science in general
and the big bang is no exception the big
bang was actually coined by one of its
uh
one of its greatest
uh detractors
a guy by the name of fred hoyle
um
he was huge in like rejecting the entire
idea when it first came out
and
when that happened
um and he didn't even like he didn't
even name it on purpose
uh usually when things get named and
there they seem like a really cool
popular name it wasn't even a scientist
it was a journalist that named it um and
so what ended up happening was he was
being interviewed uh and he was asked a
question about the big you know he was
what they called you know
cosmological expansion or whatever they
called it back then
um
and
he was like that idea is totally
ridiculous
uh
you you expect me to believe that the
universe started in some kind of big
bang
and then
the journalist published it and the name
caught on and it stuck and so that's how
that's why it's called that but it's not
actually an explosion there's there
wasn't an explosion there was just a
moment in the past
when space began to expand
that's it
it wasn't an explosion explosions would
not be this uniform
um
it is just space itself
was not expanding potentially we don't
know um but it began expanding right uh
and so
since we're getting to a point where we
accept that we don't necessarily know if
there was a time when it wasn't
expanding it might have been expanding
forever into the past
um
those eternal inflation models but uh
what we now refer to the as the big bang
is just
a time period
it's basically um
the the period in time
when
our models of physics our physics in
general
became what governed the universe
and so before that time
whatever was happening
was not governed by the laws of physics
that we know
uh and that's that's really all the big
bang was it was just it's just the time
when our models of physics became
relevant
and that was quite a long time ago and
you could easily call that the beginning
of the universe
but um
it's a little more complicated than just
an explosion
let's see
um if gr is a local model how do we use
it to model large-scale objects like
black holes galaxies etc
etc i always say that wrong
uh are shortcuts being used uh no i mean
it's
you can
you can have a local model a an equation
that applies to a single point
um but write it so generally that
applies to each individual point in
space
right so it can
you can have it applied to this specific
spot right here like right in between my
fingers
but
you could also plug in numbers for this
spot and then it would apply to that
spot you can plug in numbers for this
spot it would apply to that spot and so
you can you can do that with any local
model
but it's just important to keep in mind
that it's not
it's not a global description
it's a local description
once you know it it applies to an
individual point and that point might be
arbitrary it could be any point but it
is a point
um
curvature is a local phenomenon
if you want to talk about global
phenomenon like things that apply to the
universe as a whole
then you're not talking about curvature
you're not talking about general
relativity you're talking about topology
which is a whole other
discipline of mathematics
which i could honestly do an entire
video about
um
um
uh tommy says uh it's not a local model
you got the flrw metric which is the
metric i was just showing you
um
that that is still local it's still a
local point
right each point you might be doing
you might be modeling the universe in
broad strokes but it's still
a point
you know and if you're looking at
a large scale you know your point might
be like
you know 10 megaparsecs across which is
like i don't know i don't say like
50 million light years or something
right you could say that that
you know your point
is 50 million light years in diameter
um
but it's still just a point it's still
local it's not something that applies to
the entire universe but again this is a
language issue it's kind of hard to
to come up with
language that describes this it's so
outside of our own experience that we
just don't have the words sometimes
uh and so we're left struggling
um does the hub does hubble's law
suggest that spacetime itself is made of
a near infinite number of expanding
spheres
uh i don't think hubble's law really
implies or suggests anything
um
because
it can tell us how
you know space has expanded
throughout time
but like it's it it doesn't really say
anything about
you know
spherical bubbles all expanding together
and into each other i mean that is
one interpretation but it is not the
only interpretation and so i don't feel
like
the math is suggesting anything like
that
could there be no inside of a black hole
because in order to cross the event
horizon you would have to go greater
than c
this this is a great question and this
is something i uh
i mean we can't know until we until we
can get at least closer to one which is
dangerous but
i think
that
oh hold on
just got spam
on my chat all right so
i
as far as black hole insides go i think
there are a few ways that can go and we
can't know for sure and so at this point
it's just speculation and so i would
like to just clarify that anything i say
over the next couple of minutes is
speculation on my part but
um
it is possible that black holes don't
have an inside for multiple reasons
but
um you kind of have to look at the
models right
get some water here
and so as far as we can tell the model
works pretty well
until you get
really really close like infinitesimally
close to the event horizon when you
start to get that close to the event
horizon things start to
get weird
and i don't mean
weird weird can happen right there can
be plenty of things that happen in the
universe that are outside of our
our experience
but
there are things
that it does
that just don't actually make sense
um and so
one of the first things you notice is
that
um
different observers
can see different things happening
around black holes right so in fact
we're gonna screen share again
i've got
some graphs i can pull up here
so what i have here
is a little space-time graph
um and this orange thing here is the
light cone it's basically the future and
the past
um and each of these curves these green
and and
blue curves are paths that you can take
in space time you can see how they're
curved because space time is curved
but one of the things that we notice is
that
is that
uh
you can see that the paths that are the
paths
that are on the outside of the black
hole never cross that boundary they
never cross the uh the dashed red line
which is the event horizon they never
cross it
and so
if you are an observer
that is very very distant from the black
hole this is what you're going to see
you're going to see things falling in
and time slowing down and and things get
closer and closer and closer to the
event horizon but they never ever cross
however if you are an astronaut and you
happen to be falling into this black
hole you're going to see something very
different
your coordinates are going to look
something like this
and as you can see we've got a nice
green path here that goes right through
the event horizon and straight to the
singularity the singularity the
hypothetical singularities over here on
the left um and so you could actually
your future is pointed toward the
singularity
and your past is pointed away and that
sort of gives you an idea of what this
hypothetical singularity actually is but
the point is that the distant observer
doesn't see you cross the event horizon
but you will see yourself cross the
event horizon or at least you will cross
the point that you thought was an event
horizon
um and so you'll end up seeing something
different
than the distant observer
and so
you have to be that that's your sort of
your first hint that something is going
wrong here right there's there's an
event that exists for one person but
doesn't exist for another one
and that's kind of a a red flag in my
opinion um doesn't necessarily have to
be i could be wrong here but
uh for me that's a red flag and so
and then once you cross the event
horizon things just go off the rails
okay so then you start ending up with
like
space and time switching behaviors
um and so
um
the
in in word in that what used to be
radially inward is now the future
right what has chan has changed from
space into time um and what used to be
time
now looks like space you can actually
move back and forth in time
um
or at least it kind of all right
sorry the space is is straightforward
that is what it is right you can you can
move back and forth
but you're always going forward in time
right uh is that sort of the behavior
but now you're always going forward in
space
and so now that kind of looks like time
it's very difficult to explain um and so
that's like red flag number two right
things are getting a little wonky
um and then you have to decide well now
like do things go into the singularity
what is the singularity why does it
exist
um
why didn't some other mechanism stop the
collapse
and
uh most physicists don't think that the
the black hole singularity is actually a
thing the term like i said earlier the
term singularity just means that we
broke our model
um
and so
we are most of us are pretty sure that
there's going to be some kind of
mechanism that stops the collapse now
that's that stop
that that mechanism could stop the
collapse
after the event horizon on the inside so
there's still an enterprise and that's a
real thing but then like where though
you get a little uh iffy right you gotta
draw the line somewhere
um and i know that there are some
models out there using string theory
that
uh stop it at the event horizon like the
actual event horizon is where all the
matter is and it can't get any deeper
than that um it's sort of
a three-dimensional object has sort of
essentially been compressed into two
dimensions on the surface of the event
horizon
and so at that point asking about the
inside doesn't make any sense because
there is no inside there's no space time
there it's just the surface
there's
space time is curved so much that a
volume has become a surface
which
is also it also feels very extreme but
it is it is a possibility and so i think
that um
there are aspects of what general
relativity says about black holes that
we should be skeptical of
uh until we have a a better model that
might explain it um in a way that
doesn't like
break causality
um because there are even more red flags
after that if you've got spinning black
holes you can spiral around what we call
a regularity and travel back in time and
it's just
like i said it goes off the rails when
you get inside that event horizon and i
think those are all
indications
that we probably shouldn't trust what
general relativity says at least for the
inside of the event horizon and so it is
entirely possible that there is no
inside that is 100
a possibility
um and i personally like the idea of
that but it doesn't mean that i'm right
uh see
uh
i already answered that uh let's see
we are black holes ah
i mean
emotionally maybe right now some of some
of us
um
oh
uh let's see
lots of conversation
uh is the universe inside a black hole
i
i would say no i've even made a video
arguing the no
but uh i don't think that that's
i mean if you force it i think uh pbs
space time did a video on this if you
force it you can kind of get it to match
up but
it doesn't really actually make sense um
and so i don't think so no
uh clive recognized my um
eddington finkelstein coordinates for
the black hole thanks thanks for the the
observation
uh is it fair to say that general
relativity describes how energy and
momentum curve space-time but we have no
idea why it curves it yeah that's yes
100 accurate
um
and that's the thing with physics models
in general right we come up general
relativity is kind of our
front line
for how we explain how gravity works and
it the front line model
is always the how
that's that's what models do they
explain how and they allow us to make
predictions we want to know why but they
never really explain why
and so um
you can say okay well
newton's model of gravity said well
gravity's a force and things are you
know masses are attracted to each other
and someone says why and he's like well
i don't know i don't know why this is
just how it happens
um and then eventually you know einstein
and hilbert come along and they create
general relativity and general
relativity says well this is why things
fall
right this is the why i'm going to
answer the y
for newtonian mechanics
with a new how
and so now
we're left with a new how answer
and a why question that we don't have an
answer to and this is the the endless
chain of discovery right we we come up
with an explanation of how someone asks
why eventually someone answers that
question with a new how and so on and
the pattern continues
forever
um and that's not to say that it's
pointless because uh it's very important
that we do this because the more why
questions we manage to answer
the
more we understand about the universe
and for me that's that's one of the you
know the crowning achievements of
humanity is being able to understand the
universe around us we can understand the
whole universe we are capable
um it just takes time and we have to do
it in little steps
um all right
uh is gravity three-dimensional gravity
is four-dimensional it is for space-time
there are three dimensions of space and
one dimension of time and it is affected
by all of them right so when we talk
about gravitational waves we're talking
about waves in space and time
um which is kind of difficult to wrap
your mind around but it's
both space and time count it's not just
space
uh all right
well we're coming up an hour and a half
um we should probably call it soon
uh i was expecting to only get yeah take
an hour but uh i've gotten some really
good questions here
uh so i'll answer a few more and then
and then we'll call the stream um
uh
why is an anthropomorphic question uh
yeah so it's it's it's more about our
desire right we like to know why things
happen
um and it's definitely a driving force
for our you know scientific discovery
but like the universe doesn't care about
why it just does what it does
um
see
oh we got uh
how do we know that there is only one
dimension of time
or is it possible that time is
multi-dimensional
i mean it's possible
but
um
i mean it's possible that there are more
than three dimensions of space but
they would have to be
very confined dimensions
uh we do have models we do have
hypothetical models
none of which have been verified by
experiment but we do have hypothetical
models that have more than one dimension
of time this is a thing that is
mathematically possible
the question is whether or not it
matches our universe and we don't know
we can't know that until we do an
experiment that shows it that's why
experimental science is so important
um
doesn't the increase in space due to the
expansion uh
break newton and dark matter and dark
energy break newton's first law
um
well
no i mean
newton's first law has basically been
updated i mean that's essentially what
the geodesic equation is of f equals
zero
um
and and and that's 100 consistent with
the updated version of newton's first
law but i think
part of what you might mean is
does it violate the conservation of
energy
and the answer is yes yes it does the
conservation of energy principle is not
universal
uh general relativity does break it the
expansion of space creates more and more
dark energy over time and that energy is
actual energy that increases
uh
and so that is
a violation of conservation of energy
but that's okay we didn't expect it to
hold
um
and so just
no physicist is really all that
surprised by that
all right
uh one more little philosophical
question here and we'll call it um
it says
can you help me visualize what the
expansion of space would be i can't wrap
my head around it around emptiness being
created or emptiness expanding into
nothing
um
yeah nothingness is something that
a lot of people have a hard time with i
don't think the human brain is
is built for that uh but i think
and and i think that's why
it's a lot easier
for even for physicists to imagine that
the universe is
infinite
right so even though our observable
universe only goes out so far we can
only see so far
we
imagine that the universe continues
right we know we actually know that it
continues for a little while
just based on the fact that there's no
curvature in the cosmos overall
um
if the if the universe was only as big
as we can see there would have to be
curvature and we don't see any curvature
so we know that it's bigger
but
we we don't know how much bigger
but we do assume that
uh
it's infinite for multiple reasons one
is we don't really like the idea of an
edge and so
space would have to curve back on itself
in order to be finite
and
that is not something that
um
makes the human mind very comfortable
right to have something that doesn't go
on forever but then also doesn't have an
edge
uh and so it's a lot easier just to be
like you know what let's just assume
it's infinite it's infinite
it goes on forever
and then we don't have to worry about
edges we don't have to worry about any
of that stuff uh and so we don't have to
worry about the universe expanding into
anything because it's just infinity
getting bigger
there is nothing on the outside there's
no outside it's just
infinity and we are just over time
getting to a larger and larger amount of
infinity
um
and and i i think that's about as
good as i can do without doing like a
whole video on it but um that's that's
my best recommendation for you
is to just
just
pretend like the universe is infinite
um
just to get you through the day
uh but um on that note i think i think
i'm gonna call it
this has been uh really exciting you had
a lot of you had a lot of questions um
hopefully i
i tried to answer what i could uh there
were definitely some questions in here
that i did not have answers for uh
because frankly i i couldn't possibly
know everything
um
but
but uh thank you all for coming thank
you for
uh all your questions and your
participation this has been this has
been really great
and
uh
on that note i guess um i'll see in the
comments my videos
thanks everybody for coming